there are two types of availability in
tungl me weekly template and daily
exceptions here's how to edit them for
weekly template we'll select edit
availability weekly template from the
public profile
dropdown here we can select the days and
times each week that we want to make
available simply click and drag on the
calendar view to add or remove avail
ability when you're happy with your
choices click
save what you set here will be displayed
across each week on your public
profile you'll notice that when you have
an event in your connected calendar
tungle will automatically remove that
from your public
profile now we'll look at Daily
exceptions we go back to the public
profile dropdown
and select edit availability daily
exceptions with daily exceptions you can
make daily or weekly exceptions to your
public
profile what you set here will only be
saved for that specific day and won't be
duplicated across all weeks in your
calendar simply click and
drag to make available spots
unavailable or unavailable spots
available save your
selection and now we can see on your
profile the daily changes you've
made and that's how to set availability
in tungl
me